foreign
[Music]
hey guys what's going on I will be in
Charlotte and I will be in Knoxville
this weekend so go get tickets and I
will be in Little Rock Arkansas
and uh different places like you know
Cleveland I don't even know honestly
where I'm gonna be oh a lot of a lot of
Canadian dates and I know people want me
to come to Vancouver and I'm not not
going to kind of Vancouver I am going to
come to Vancouver but that's next year
and I haven't posted about it yet but I
will be in Nashville soon and
um like I said a lot in Canada
Pittsburgh Cleveland Detroit
Fort Myers Florida for some reason
Richmond Virginia didn't have a clue I
was going to be there but I am
um and Baltimore Maryland had no clue
but I'm gonna be there and then Reading
Pennsylvania and Philadelphia
Pennsylvania and Pennsylvania but
Redding president for some reason not
Philadelphia's for some reason but
anyway you know go to chrisley.com and
get them tickets and uh and there you
have it we all also got some beautiful
gorgeous merch man what the heck what
the Frank check this merch out the
pockets stay deep people know that
you're loaded because you got them
diving boards above your pockets because
the pockets are absolutely the pockets
are absolutely the deepest thing I've
ever seen they're deeper than the abyss
they're deeper than the movie you know
in in the bedroom or whatever that one
is with Nick Stahl uh it's a deep movie
about a family tragedy but there is all
it is so deep as deep as if dude did
they film my did they film in the
bedroom in my pocket
so we got the pockets stay deep
uh merch and then
um
life ribs decal so you could sport it
out and then the grower die hoodies was
oh God it's just like come on dude
come on grow or die look at them look at
them right there they're beautiful so uh
anyway without further uh rambling
uh let's get into some rambling on the
new episode of congratulations
[Music]
every time my producers go like do the
thing where they do
I think of Wayne's World and that's fine
because they did it in Wayne's World and
they do it all the time and that's
honestly
that means you're a legit radio State uh
TV station and I'm a legit TV station so
I'm not a TV station I'm a TV station
um
so uh so
man I mean it's been a help dude Los
Santos went through the storm they got
their first hurricane ever in history
what a hurricane Hillary
wow I'm just like to the storm just like
lock her up dude
I'm just like but her emails but the
storm's emails that's how I go like that
but man we got like eight inches of rain
or something I live on a hill dude man
there was it was gushing that it was
like uh that uh it was like a universal
uh Studios ride La at California
whatever La is not equipped for the
storm and it's okay there was mild wind
now let me ask let me actually talk
about this dude
they do category one two three four five
right
it only means the wind
that doesn't account for rainfall now
what the heck I'm not a barometerist but
it's like dude
account for the water you know
come on man
account for the water the water is the
thing that makes the flights have more
people die from the water than they do
from the wind I mean come on dude that's
either true or I made it up but it's
like come on dude
you see all these floods and all this
stuff and remember when Fort Myers had
that crazy one
the whole city was underwater
jeez it's just like and I just learned
that
but Fort Myers was all under what I'll
be in Fort Myers also chrisley.com
coming up soon here but dude it's just
like make it screw this wind stuff it's
really about the Rain Man
uh so come on the government clean it up
come on botanists or whatever not
botanist barometers or you know
weathered people
I like how weathermen can be like fours
and fives but if you're a a woman a
female weather woman whether female you
gotta be a just all-out ten you know
and also
that's where the sentence ends actually
but dude you just got to be an all-out
ten you turn on any Weather Channel if
there's a female doing and she said
there's a front coming in and there
should be a front here let's check this
out
there's a front coming in dude and
you're just like dude you're just like
you go
your tongue comes out
like that scene from The Mask
dude and you're just and then a guy and
then a guy by the way why are there male
weather men
and I'm not you know look
I'm not sexist and I I was sexist I'm a
reformed sexist I'm not anymore but I'm
also I'm not crazy woke you know I'm not
woke at all
I'm not woke I hate that
but it's like who the who the who the
[__] wants to listen to the Dallas
Reigns
and his orange face
all right we got a killed front dude I
want to see some you know what I mean I
want to see somebody with a back seat on
her I'm not trying to be like but you
know
sometimes I I do this podcast and I
think about Calvin listening to it when
he's like 25 and I'm just like oh well
hopefully he'll like it hey son
I meant all of this every word
[Laughter]
oh man so uh I mean everything I say on
this podcast and that's why it's not a
comedy podcast that's why it's an
absolute drama I have the only drama
podcast and I don't I know there's
storytelling like the whole thing with
um and there he was
found himself Stark naked in the middle
of a field holding a decapitated head I
know they have those
story like they tell real stuff and they
do like stories
like the I saw this I listened to this
podcast uh the girl in the blue Mustang
or something
where they arrested the wrong guy and
then he got out and the family still
thinks he did it and it's like
but this podcast is a drama
um and it's the only one where a guy
just straight up talks to you and it's a
drama so anyway whatever dude it's like
go go to other guys for your comedy [__]
like Tim Dylan and who else has a solo
podcast I don't even really know anymore
um
but yeah so
uh
uh the storm was was kind of cool
I stayed in we stayed in I mean dude I
gotta be honest Kristen was like
there's gonna be a hurricane and I was
like it'll be fine and she's like I'm
from North Carolina and I was like okay
well so you you're saying you've been
through hurricanes and she was like yes
I I know what we have to do and I was
like it's actually it's fine she's like
we're gonna flood we need sandbags I was
like we're not gonna flood because we're
on a hill you can't flood if you're on a
hill it just keeps going the water will
just keep going
and she was like we gotta go to the fire
local fire department to have them for
free we'll get Sam I'm like no dude
we'll just we won't flood it'll be fine
it's not even gonna and then I started
saying like dude it's never gonna get to
us like it's going to dissipate before
we even get it even gets here to LA and
she was like no no no no and then we
give a joke and I was like it's not even
gonna happen
and then even as the rain was coming
down I was like dude the storm's not
coming and we were laughing we're having
a good we were having a laugh you know
what I mean that's just like kind of
like husband and wife material but uh
they were just laughing at each other
you know what I mean but but beforehand
she was like get dude
when my wife hears about something like
a natural disaster it's Defcon 5.
it's deaf con there's gonna be a
hurricane she goes like this get three
generators go now Home Depot they're
gonna be sold out hurry up you're gonna
be the first one there
not we need we need we need a a we need
a generator it needs to have 20 000
Watts it needs to be capable of 20 000
watts and and at least a 17 000 Watts
run uh run rate and then and then you
need to go get 90 you need to go get 90
extension cords
and I'm just like and get 70 cans of
propane and 45 gas tanks and and I'm
just like dude it's gonna be fine she's
like what if the power goes out we have
a baby we have two babies we have a baby
we have three babies including you and
I'm like I get it that's funny and she
was like yeah but you know what about
the milk in the fridge and all that it's
gonna be so I go out I get the [__]
generator dude
you know it's like it's like 8 000 Watts
it'll power enough it'll power the
fridge and the [__] and the people at
the Home Depot I'm like hey can I get
somebody by the way
160 people work at Home Depot
it's insane you go there half of the
people and there are a lot of customers
half of the people there
straight up
work there they have or they're just
dressed with orange
Home Depot shirts for no reason because
dude I couldn't believe it
I couldn't
and they're all like it's like a little
city they're just driving around on
forklifts and [__]
just so slow just
be need help you're like looking at the
cookies they have for some reason you
know
and then I love to go in that section
where there's there's a 50 000 lamps and
they're all on
but I'm like I'm like hey you know 160
people work there and then I'm like hey
can I get some help I need to know what
what the [__] generator will do
but you never can talk right away to the
guy who knows what's up they always go
yeah let me um all right let me get uh
and you're like oh you know then the guy
comes by how can I help you yeah can I
get the [__] there's that funny bit the
Sebastian Maniscalco bit where he's like
hey what's the difference between this
and this another guy goes uh and then
Sebastian says he's gonna make it up
dude that's what they do they're gonna
make they [__] they make it up
and um
and he's like yeah this one takes Pro
they just read the [__] thing they're
like this one takes Propane and Gas so
you might want that one and the way they
say it I'm like I might want that one I
don't know I have [__] gas or propane
do you guys got gas here no do you have
propane here yeah then I want the
[__] profane one
good thing I want to go to Arco and
Philip
just loose bags of
unleaded fuel and just and then just
have it in my garage
God forbid my you know you know
my son takes a [__] sparkler down
there or something on 4th of July
so uh
it took so long to get the [__]
generator and the propane tank dude and
the guy was wearing a mask and it's like
dude take it off
don't the worker was wearing a mask and
then that's fine but then I saw another
worker without one so it's like take it
off
I understand if that's your company rule
you gotta do it or you get fired okay
fine that sucks but if you can't beat
him join them but if you don't have to
take it off
so now I'm like
all right so
you know I'm grabbing all this other
[__] too because it's so much like
I'm like oh I want I'm the [__]
sucker that's in the line where I'm like
ooh certs you know
oh Tic Tacs and ooh dude oh kind bars by
the way if you've ever eaten a kind bar
and you like it that's the enemy right
there kind bars are so bad dude kind
bars every single kind bar are [__]
absolute trash every Co and the name
kind dude I'll do a soft kick to it I'll
tell you what man kind bars dude eat the
blueberry one it's worse than the
chocolate one it's worse than the Walnut
one it's worse than the [__] um
almond dude they're all bad and they
stick to your teeth dude they're so what
are kind bars who are they for that's
the enemy
you see someone eating a kind bar that's
I swear to God that's the enemy I'm I'm
telling you dude you can't trust
somebody who likes a kind bar because
they think they're eating it for [__]
because they think it's good for you a
little bit they think it's a better
version a more healthier version than
the stickers even though it's not you
know an arena kind bar and they they
don't know really what's going on you
can't trust a [__] that eats a
kind bar because they're just sitting
there thinking they're doing something
you know like they've been somewhere
God like they never traveled but to tell
you about the [__]
Stonehenge that's the kind of guy who
kind bars well I've never been but you
know the reason why that is that is a
kind bar either if I've ever heard it
and they got kind bars that [__] Home
Depot I don't like how every store also
sells water
you know every single store sells water
every store
you go in and you can also get water it
doesn't matter what it's you go to Home
Depot get water bottles of water and
then in 1970 bottles of water weren't
even a [__] thing
and that's either true or I made it up
but then bottles of water [__]
happened
and now you would be like remember what
the [__] about I remember when I was
young about his water or something with
a bottle of water what a [__] prissy
[__] you just drink out of the sink
and yeah but it has lead in it and
you're like does it okay I'll get a
bottle of water and he realized it's not
that bad sometimes the sink water is
better than the [__] Dasani [__]
Dasani tastes like a [__] someone
it's somebody's leftover colonic [__]
yeah
and uh
so
now they just sell you know water
just everywhere go to a vape shop hey
dude you got it they got it yeah we got
the right there in the in the fridge
you're a vape shop dude
you know you sell terrible [__] don't
act also like oh yeah you may need a
water
I swear to God I went to a place I went
to [__] Lids they were like dude if
you need they had a Powerade water
[__] fridge at lids
every place has one and then now bro I
was saying this to my brother and my
brother goes like this dude what about
water shops and I go like this what
he's like yeah there are places that you
can that just sell water
and I said well no there's not and he
said yes there are and I go link me
to there's places you can just buy water
probably
run by the Russian mafia
I swear to God there's places you can
just go buy water dude imagine shopping
there just like
what a piece of [__] you know oh let me
get the um
the pH do you have a p
I don't know I remember one time I was
[__] Whitney Comics was trying to
tell me about the water and how you
gotta have this because it's got the pH
and I'm just like oh yeah
didn't do [__] kept drinking that
[__] whatever I was drinking
you got to be wary about people who eat
kind bars and talk about water too much
for real as I sip on my [__]
Arrowhead
people think it's pond water I don't
give a [__] dude
oh there's tadpoles in my belly
so anyway dude
um I drink water and I drink uh coffee
and I drink uh
club soda and that's [__] the most
interesting thing I've ever said so go
eat my dick and I'll tell you what one
time I asked my uncle Vinnie I said hey
what do you drink and he goes like this
water and I
and I said oh yeah anything else and he
goes like this water and I said so
anything you don't just drink water or
anything and you're like water and dude
he did it three or four times and I
can't I think about that all the time
dude my dude he wanted to laugh he
wanted to laugh out of me water like
just
so I drink a lot of water I go to the
gym and I sweat it up and I know I talk
about the gym a lot but dude this is not
even I actually have a story about it
I know I joke around about how I got the
teardrops and all that and yeah I do
it's fine right
there I got the hamstrings that'll choke
someone out and I get it and that's fine
and that's cool right
like I walk around like I'm a you know
what I mean like I could be it doesn't I
can run backwards just as fast as I can
run forwards okay
but what I'm saying is
yes I do work out and I'm no stranger to
the gym the iron Paradise I get it I'm
the mayor of this [__] place I need
to go on I need to check the citizens
you know what I'm saying
uh uh
so I go
and I get I got I go to the gym and I'm
working it out I'm sweaty as [__] you
know
go back to a grocery store after that
I'm shopping some dude comes up to me I
know I know I joke around about how I do
legs all the time but check this out
for size once you [__] Feast your
eyes on
Feast your ears on listening to this if
you're watching the if you're watching
the show Feast your eyes on me saying
this
but the guy comes up to me says hey man
you work out at the gym right did I go
to and I was like oh yeah what's up bro
he's like hey man cool and I said cool
man
he says
hey man
um
you work out legs a lot
and I say oh yeah man I do I work out
legs you know I think that's the most
important thing to work out and you guys
like this yeah man and he said respect
and I go thanks yeah thanks man yeah
walks away
dude are you kidding me
[Music]
foreign
[__] talk about making my day dude
I walked out of that place
[Music]
and it was just
I mean it was killer
I mean yeah I go to the gym it's
operation do it to him but it's just
like it's absolutely you know it's crazy
dude
respect who even says that anymore it's
like it's
respect
yeah
dude I was on the couch today
early in the morning my wife got up with
the kids
and uh
and I was still sleeping and then she
came in
she came in at like nine almost came in
at nine and uh she said hey babe I got
the worst sleep last night I couldn't
sleep can you get up and and be with the
kids while I take a nap and I go like
this sure a nap at nine that's [__]
Bonkers insane but sure at nine you
should still be riding the ice slept
even if it was just for four hours but
she hadn't
she did a good nap at nine it's all good
so I go yeah sure I get it let me get up
dude yeah look at my resentful yeah but
do I do it yeah does my back hurt yeah
is it okay no it [__] hurts still and
I still worked out but it's fine okay
it's ultimately fine
I'm just gonna work out until my back
breaks
and
and so I go downstairs
and I see Calvin and William William is
in a Boppy can't even [__] sit up yet
you know he's four months old
and Calvin is
sitting on the couch
watching StoryBots on Netflix which he
likes it's a cute show
and I'm talk I'm looking at William
who's in front of Calvin and Calvin says
to me
actually we want to watch the TV
actually let's watch the TV and I look
because I was in front of the TV like
that is so gangster that is so gangster
and I love him for that but then
I'm chilling I'm watching StoryBots I'm
you know I'm on the couch with Calvin
and Calvin says oh no and I said what he
says you spilled my milk
and I look oh at Calvin who is on the
other pillow on the other side of the
couch like I can't actually even reach
him unless I move and go touch him
and he's holding his milk sippy cup
and I say
huh and he says you spilled my milk
and I said
I I'm not even over there
dude he's three
and now I'm like am I about to get an
argument with the [__] with the
three-year-old
he said you smell my milk and I said
well Calvin I'm not even over there I I
didn't even touch your milk
and he says oh you spilled it and I said
who spilled it and he said you
and I said
well actually
I took a [__] video of it
and I'm gonna play it
hold on right here
hold on hold on Kevin who spilled the
milk
I don't know okay well who's holding the
Okay so
let's build it I don't know it's anybody
yeah
it spells so well so it spilled when you
were holding it
so who spilled the milk
that was me
cracked him
cracked him that's like the end of the
[__] movie and justice for all when
Al Pacino almost looks into the camera
just like he's innocent dude cracked him
dude how awesome is that that you can
just crack
someone like that even though yeah it
was three but it's just like just
knowing that you got him you know I'm
like I'm like I'm like leading them down
that path you know I'm leading them down
the back like dude I swear to God other
lawyers would be like objection you're
leading the witness and dude but I'm
just like he's three
dude and I just let him down I just held
his hand I just took a little stroll of
them and at the end what was there to
spilled milk and who was holding it to
him
and then he goes it was me I cracked
them dude holy [__]
[__] Johnny Cochran in the absolute
easy
so anyway dude
I'm also a good dad though check this
out
but it was an accident right
that's okay do you want me to get more
bro so I kind of had a happy or anything
than you thought but I still did [__]
crack them dude that's great
he was crying over spilled milk you know
um
bro wait wait wait actually let's look
up this thing this is hilarious
that that
Bradley Cooper
they can't stop doing it I I don't know
I don't know
I don't know about
this [__] where because people that you
had the junos on or whatever the [__]
the big big nose and then they
look at this
look at this well so now they're coming
out with daughter who's like why Bradley
Cooper's fake nose may not be an
anti-semitic Scandal critics claim did
this the best because the dude had a big
ass Honker and yay happened to be Jewish
a lot they made it bigger than it
actually is though didn't they they got
a side by side here the guy had a nice
nose and they rather Coopers playing the
Jewish guy and they they beefed up his
nose look at this
Hollywood cast look look at this dude
these stop anti-semitic and stop
anti-Semitism there's not enough just
get the real [__] you know what I'm
saying get on Kanye talk about Hitler
still
Hollywood cast Bradley Cooper ananju to
play that's fine by the way dude it's
fine it's so annoying remember acting
[__] Al Pacino put a goddamn Cuban in
the
push it to the Limit Scarface whatever
it was
oh yeah oh say hello to my little friend
that was
a white guy playing a not white guy
acting now I get it white people have
had more opportunity and isn't that all
okay the other thing and I get it that's
not right yes I get that okay that's
fine but also dude it's okay if Bradley
Coop Dogg plays a Jew
all right
it's acting it's not like he's gonna be
out there like oh oh my god oh we
spilled all the matzah like he's not
gonna be doing that oh you vague I don't
know how to park the car it's all got
these different Gadgets in it
it's not like he's gonna be like that
oh boy
that's too it's not like he's walking
around like oh that's too expensive what
do we do he's just [__] Nate you know
the guy had a little bit of a bigger
nose and and and and Bradley Cooper
the makeup the makeup people are
probably Jewish and by the way it's
Hollywood so the [__] producers were
Jewish
so Hollywood cast Bradley Cooper and
non-jew to play Jewish Legend Leonard
Bernstein wow he's Jewish uh and stuck a
disgusting exaggerated junos on him this
is what the stop anti-Semitism from
Twitter is saying by the way
being anti-semitic saying it this way
you know
anti-semitic when you're trying to stop
anti-Semitism and you said stuck a
disgusting exaggerated junos on them um
hey
chill
all while saying no to Jake Gyllenhaal
and actually Jewish man who has dreamed
of playing Bernstein for decades
sickening hey check this out dude Joe
I'll tell you what Jake gylleno is such
a good actor he would have [__] done
workouts to get his nose bigger for real
Jake Gyllenhaal goes like Jake
Gyllenhaal is the [__] because he knows
how [__] of a profession acting is so
he's like you know what dude I'm gonna
play a [__] lion tamer put me in a a
cage with lions for a year and a half
because acting is one ticket to
pussyville and I am going to make it a
hard job so I can [__] become the guy
dude what you saw that movie Southpaw
Hey Jake gylleno is a boxer in it dude
his body is building a sh a a [__]
Brickhouse brick I can't ever break [__]
out what the [__] is it I don't know
he's he's stacked dude he's so stacked I
would never like I'm not gay but I would
you know
I jerk off in a room with him
if he was doing it too and just like
right it's crazy and
dude
he's so good he would think his nose
bigger and he's Jewish which is fine I
didn't know Jake gyllenha was Jewish but
Bradley Cooper is not Jewish and he goes
like this knows me
others proclaimed it's Jew face I like
they're trying to to hop on the
bandwagon a black face when it's like
that was actually a thing you know uh
the suggestion is that portrayal of
Bernstein by Cooper is a non-jew is it
dude I can't wait till the pendulum
swings and I'm playing a [__] Asian I
swear to God
an Asian woman not trans
an Asian woman born as a woman
never thought about changing genders
just straight up and I'm 11 in it
you know just [__] caked on the
makeup
just they have to [__] film every
time they film me talking to an adult
they have to dig a hole and I stay I
have to stand in it
because I gotta appear shorter than
[__] Colin Firth or whoever else is
in it
to me the answer is okay so so let's see
what there so the the suggestion is that
portrayal of Bernstein by Cooper is
non-jew is akin to the deeply offensive
practice of blackface it's not it's not
news flash it's not in which white
actors once done dark makeup okay yeah
this was bad okay this was bad okay
um and that brings us to our initial
question can a Jew be incredibly
portrayed by a non-jew
to me the answer is unambiguous
absolutely draw drawing from my own
experiences if I were still in the
acting profession
to limit myself only to playing Italian
or Puerto Rican roles
would just do they should have honestly
for real got the guy from the Allstate
commercials to play this guy
to play and and gave him a big nose and
white faced him
and just have him be like I'm Leonard
I'm Leonard
I'm famous Hollywood producer Leonard
Bernstein
that's my plan
is he doing the Allstate thing
why is he standing in the middle of a
street during this whole movie
[Laughter]
dude bro you know what the [__] what's
that guy's name from Allstate
Dennis Haysbert dude that guy is the
most distinguished man in the world dude
I swear to God that guy's so
distinguished he doesn't [__]
so distinguished he like he'll fall in
love with a woman straight off looks and
she'll fall in love too
and then she says well don't we have to
make love at some point and he just goes
like this
we don't have to
and they get married and have kids
without insemination that's how
respectable
and if you don't talk about I'm talking
about the [__] president in 24. it's
so crazy how they made a black president
on TV before it happened in real life
dude that's hilarious
that's so backwards
um Dennis Haysbert for president and I
mean it but he is in the one of the top
[__] I would say at least top 10
movies or I would say maybe top five
movies I saw it last night dude Dennis
haysberg is in the movie and I finally
saw it for the first time and I've been
saving this movie because I thought it
would be good to watch and I wanted to
save it till I could appreciate it and
dude
it is the it is first of all I'm going
to go ahead and say it it's it's unfair
to call it an action movie
but it is
but it is the greatest action movie of
all time
period
and that movie is Heat
[Music]
dude are you I watched first of all
Kristen goes like this let's watch a
movie and I say well what do you want to
watch and she says let's watch Oscar
nominated movies now your voice Cinema
hey because he's cultured hey it's all
good hey you see them all oh
but I'm shifted to this some I haven't
seen right turn on The Insider hey watch
The Insider oh good Russell Crowe he's
pretty good
it was good
Russell core is great
Insider's Good Michael Mann directed it
so what popped off after what popped up
after that I never saw Insider I know it
was nominated for best picture or
something uh Russell Crow was nominated
for best actor
um that's by the way really funny that
Russell Crowe was not me for best actor
and Al Pacino wasn't nominated for best
actor you know Al Pacino was like oh
that okay whoa hey good good for oh
that's great good for good for the
Aussie oh yeah good for where where the
[__] you from where's he from
all right
there you go
who won
is that about heat what let me see
oh no
they're gonna remake it
oh this Oh I thought it was the prequel
prequel
all right well so I mean I gotta watch
it
okay Adam driver's gonna be in a prequel
to heat okay that's fine that's okay I
think that that's great I always want to
make prickles I think they should make
only prequels I don't think they should
ever make sequels sequels are a recipe
for disaster the [__] is done
it's over if it's a great movie it's all
wrapped up
and then more dude always make a prequel
[__] you make so much sense is that
crystallia I think so
dude just make a prequel
boom money you get the money and you get
this if it's good you get this how many
sequels are better than
two right they got [__] um Terminator
and Godfather right or no not Godfather
what's the other one I don't know
[__] there's one or two
um and so
thank you man Kristen is like let's
watch it so we watch inside the next she
falls is even 20 minutes yes dude now
I'm stuck watching Russell Crowe do a
[__] American accent I swear to God
20 minutes in 20 minutes in let's watch
a [__] wait I almost want to watch a
good movie I've seen a lot of the Oscar
winners so let's just watch the let's
watch the
we'll watch a one that got nominated a
lot okay cool instead of oh she goes oh
I said go play 20 minutes later Kristen
Kristen wig from Bridesmaids on the
plane just and so now I gotta watch the
rest of the movie I don't want to
because it's three hours dude movies
should only be two hours period
we should be an hour I I swear for real
even Pocahontas is too long and that's
like an hour and 10 minutes
um and so now
and the next night what pops up in the
algorithm heat why because it's my
command all right dude I'm in look I
like the way Michael man does it I
really like it I really like the way he
does it dude and in his Heyday in the
90s he was apparently the [__] and I
just saw Insider and it was great so I'm
like okay I'm on a Michael mansion
so I turn on heat because she says let's
watch a movie I say okay she said but
let's go in the bedroom I don't like to
watch movies or anything or do anything
in bed except sleep and doing but she
wants to hang out in the bed like it's a
[__] like it's hide
she wants to hang out in the bed like
it's a [__] like it's an apple Beast
like it's so she's well why can't we go
up and I'm like uh can we watch a movie
and can you not be on your phone and can
we not go to sleep and if we if we can
do that then okay she says okay what
more you want to see I say heat she goes
like this okay so I go like this
the Dax stacked she said it now this is
a good thing because either I get to
watch the whole movie Heat or I catch
her in a like even better the next
morning I wake up and I go like this
well well well I come down like some
crazy [__] villain well somebody fell
asleep there didn't they what you don't
know is I've already poisoned your cup
your coffee
um so
I'm watching so we turn on heat
and I go like this huh
right off the bat interesting there's so
many moving pieces what the [__] who's
this guy I keep doing that because I
keep introducing more characters and
then I forget about the characters and
then go back to the characters and I go
like this huh forgot about that guy but
yeah I guess he is going through his own
kind of mental turmoil
I watch
the movie I had a mouth was open 85
percent of the time
and not cause I was eating
I legit
that movie is so good and I can't stop
thinking about it yes now I know
everyone's only like it's [__] heat
dude you should have watched it you
should have watched it already but I was
saving it and I'm so glad I did because
now I'm 43 and I got to watch heat when
I was 43 when the [__] did you get to
see heat when you couldn't appreciate it
no
my brother asked me when he was going to
when has Calvin scene jingle all the way
and I say he's not ready yet he says how
he's not ready he's three and a half I
say because dude think about it you're
watching movie during Christmas and last
Christmas he wasn't even three next
Christmas he'll [__] watch it
can't wait to watch jingle all the way
with Calvin and that's the point of this
whole story but he is awesome to Jingle
All The Way is [__] hilarious
oh the turbo man I got to get the table
man
Sinbad should be in legitimately every
single movie Sinbad is one of the
funniest dude that guy in movies is the
funniest
house guest dude when his hands were on
them was that him or was that Phil
Harmon doing the thing dude when his
hands are all numb holy and the turbum a
good look at the table man I get to get
the table man
oh dude they really killed jingle all
the way
um
but anyway
uh
uh oh this clip is
I think this might be you talk about
up your alley this might be the most up
my alley [__]
I can't even believe did
has this guy ever this guy must have had
the best mom of all time
to think he could get away with this lie
I didn't go to college but um I turned
it down oh yeah I turned it down just to
do this just the ground from the rap so
you had an opportunity to do the driving
thing a scholarship and everything rap
um I think it was like in Jacksonville
yeah big a big band in Jacksonville it's
a big college though they're lying and
they offered me like
fitting some [__] like 10 million or
something like that five million
something like that so different
a scholarship
okay but not five million dollars
Fatin asked me 15 offered me 15 10
million five five million dollars or
something like that hey man you're not
175 years old you remember you're 30.
dude
yeah
what the [__] are we doing here
like what I'm saying but I was so
younger like wait wait I didn't know
what it was are you sure the average you
five million dollars
it's hard to down
he was a scholarship like I had to go to
school for this decade
this guy
this guy another ship is [__] this guy's
talking about employment dude this is
such a I had to go for college this
decade I had to go to college for this
decade right to get paid at it was 15 or
5 million dollars
I didn't go to college but um I turned
it down oh yeah I turned it down just to
do this just the ground from the rap so
you had an opportunity to do the drug
thing a scholarship and everything rap
um oh god dude where'd you get a
scholarship from
um dude making it up
the city he picked was perfect though
because it's a big city that nobody
really knows about Jacksonville you know
if he was like
honestly any other big city would have
[__] that up Chicago oh well what is
it oh no Jacksonville be like people
give you Grace with that
I think it was like in Jacksonville
yeah big a big band in Jacksonville it's
a big college though and they offered me
like
fitting some [__] like 10 million or
something like that five million
something like that
a scholarship okay but not five million
dollars this is the the best part this
guy's so good at like this guy had the
best mom of all time because he he he
his mom was always like you know you
could do anything and you're the best he
would trip and fall and she would be
like that's the ground fall honey
like this guy just believes in himself
whatever he's saying no matter what
they have to do five million dollars
that my favorite part is when he goes
yeah
what the [__] are we doing here for
y'all like that's what I'm saying but I
was so younger like so yeah are you sure
they average you five million dollars
[Laughter]
dude the deflection didn't say yes or no
turned it down
dude
you want to be why can't I be friends
with guys like this
I try
try to be friends with guys like this
you know
but it's like
I can't because they're just utterly
[__] terrible you know what who is
this guy a football player rapper
because he would get a scholarship for
sports right not for rapping but he said
I'm in his rap game
I mean this guy's so confused you know
that's the best lie I've ever heard in
my life
and it's such a good lie that I believe
him
school for this decade
it was a scholarship like I had to go to
the best was
the face when he realized he could say
he had to go to school for the decade
like he's like oh I could get away with
this
um
dude the [__] uh Domino's Pizza will
close all 142 stores in Russia is this
because of the [__] War
oh wow dude
that's crazy
hey your pizza
hey
cheese and bread
imagine Russians just like
they're doing what
like dude first of all Russians don't
give a [__] about anything and they
don't even have to eat
for real they don't they could go
dude Russians are so hardcore
they can do they could easily go and I
mean and I mean easily they could
easily go you know the football player
that says he's only been drinking water
for three months Russians laugh in that
guy's face Russians can go
and I mean it easily they could go and
I'm a scientist so you know this but
they could go
180 days without eating
180 days and drinking only every third
day
at day 180 they would be like
a hip to maybe eat something and they
drink Tabasco sauce and they'd be like
this is good enough
dude Russians don't you think dominoes
what the [__] are they gonna do dude oh
Domino's
imagine a Russian being like they're
taking dominoes away from this I don't
care we have so many Pizza I can just
eat whatever but also it doesn't matter
just because Domino's did this I will
now not eat till War is Over
[__] them
140 dude that's a huge hit this just
means that Domino's was failing in
Russia by the way
there's no way if it was lucrative that
they would ever do this there is no
[__] way
imagine and also how about everyone
who's just out of a job these aren't
even the [__] things that are the
problem
now you got people that are just like I
can't see feed my family
with the money I make from Domino's or
Domino's
[__] this
I hope everybody dies in this war
um
the company that owns franchise writes
for the Domino's Pizza brand in Russia
turkey okay said Monday will be file for
bankruptcy okay yeah there you go the
move highlights the increasing hard
choices facing Western firms that stayed
in Russia after the start of the Ukraine
war the Kremlin has made I don't like
that they say the Kremlin dude that's so
annoying like it's a [__] like it's
you know what I mean like he's like it's
Thanos it's just a the Kremlin what does
it even mean just [__] Russia
what does it mean
the Kremlin is like saying the White
House changed the [__] name dude just
at least say the Kremlin house
Kremlin sounds like it's like
they're like little like
you know
hey hey get out of here this is the
Kremlin
you know what I mean
reality
oh you scaly yes I'm the crime line
the Kremlin has made it vastly more
difficult to and more costly for Western
companies to sell their Russian
businesses
and it has in some cases cease control
of firms local assets and all right so
with increasing Leach it's a quote it
was increasingly challenging our
environment DPR Russia DP Russia's
immediate holding company is now
compelled to take this step which will
bring about the termination of the
attempted sale process of DP Russia as
going concerning what the [__] are they
saying
the company operates 142 stores in
Russia and the country's third largest
pizza delivery business
That's crazy dude
hopefully it's not a domino effect no
come on dude I don't do those kinds of
jokes who am I [__] Mark Norman I
don't do those jokes
they're jokes though you know and they
work sometimes uh Market Norman's gonna
um
bro
how unbelievable is it that people just
straight up stopped talking about
thinking about
uh uh nfts
if you bought an nft and let me tell you
right now if you bought an nft Ever
you're a piece of [__] okay
you piece of [__] no why it was nothing
okay it was nothing it was the most
nothing hey blockchain the [__] out of
here hey what are you okay
hey
get out of here man oh yeah you're a
[__] ape face on it ah cool what's it
doing boom boom what's it got a [__]
noise maker hey how much is it ah hey
the [__] out of here huh oh dude oh oh
but it's a blockchain owen has created
in the thing and oh dude that doesn't
matter oh what do I get I'll get nothing
ah cool man hey Move Along
dude
then this is the kind of person that you
don't want the you don't want business
from somebody who would buy [__] nfts
and this is why but because they're
idiots and then this is why buyers of
board ape nfts Sue after digital Apes
turn out to be bad investment dude
you're a bro you know what I mean you
made a bad investment because you
[__] idiot and now you're gonna sue
the person because of what what it
didn't promise they made promises on it
is a certain thing and it's not living
up to its what are you suing it for it's
nothing it never was anything dude
look at this lawsuit bees sue the bees
24 million solebees how do you say
Sotheby's 24 million sail to FTX gave
board ape nfts an air of legitimacy so
oh dude I wish I was the judge on this
case
so gank
jury everything's gone done go
what do they say
at the end the soothebees auction house
has been named as a defendant in the
lawsuit filled by filed by investors who
regret buying who regret buying board
ape Yacht Club nfts that sold for highly
inflatable Parts dude this is crazy
this [__] [__] these guys are
idiots
these are like chicks that are like no
but I shouldn't have and then they're
like he that's bad of him dude you made
a choice a choice as an adult to buy a
[__] not even a picture of a gold ape
with an earring on it and glasses that
[__] dipla would wear dude you chose
it you paid thousands and you're gonna
Seuss dude I hope these guys don't see a
[__] red scent
look at this
Yuga
Yuga labs
investors previously sued board a
creator
yoga labs for company Executives for
company accessories and are very
celebrity promoters including Paris
Kevin Hart Snoop Dogg sir and Williams
from Donna Jesus Christ and Justin
Bieber The Original Classic they would
suit them oh God and so the bees was
everyone's trying to get money off these
modified if you dude this is was added
as a defendant so okay so Yuga describes
its collection of ten thousand board
nfts as unique digital Collectibles
living in the
ethereum blockchain AG [__] out of here
move along Move Along
that double as a yacht club membership
card
so so what it's nothing you bought
nothing congrats
when you buy a board ape you're not
simply buying an avatar or a provably
rare piece of art
you are gaining membership access to a
club whose benefits and offerings will
increase over time wow your board ape
can serve as your digital identity and
open Digital doors for you
imagine hearing that and being like cut
the check
hey dude you know what I gotta get my
business manager on the phone cut the
check
cut the check we're buying nothing
what is the law that they seem to have
broken
they soared and then plummeted
look at this there was border it peaked
that over
420 000 in April 22 but plummeted to
about ninety thousand six weeks later
how it's still nothing how is it even
ninety thousand dollars
yeah granted I don't understand it but
also it's always been nothing
's crazy huh all good
um
unreal
I hope they all die
um
what's this here
30 talk about the [__]
did I already talk about the Flash The
Flash must be terrible I haven't seen it
it must be so bad
I want to see it I guess
The Flash is so it's got to be so bad I
can't wait to see it
The Flash is now the worst box office
flop in superhero film history even over
Shazam I can't believe that
Shazam looked [__] [__] sucking
terrible just three weeks after Warner
Brothers Ezra Miller starring DC he's
done Ezra Miller huh now he can I
thought the only hope he had was to this
would be a box office smash making only
55 million uh that's crazy they promoted
the shint out of that I don't swear
um
budget of 220 million plus 150 million
in promotional budget holy Christ that's
what people don't realize is the
promotional thing this is why I say
Bobby Bobby Bond because I know the
promotional uh money for Barbie was over
five billion dollars so
Barbie [__] bombed dude
greatest Financial loss suffered by a
studio over a super dude how do they pay
150 million on marketing when they
couldn't even use the main character
actor in The Promo stuff because he's
just so weird hey I'm like the flash or
whatever oh my God it's like so how do
you feel about the legend oh he's like
so fast like oh my God he's like so fast
um there's a little lipstick and a
[__] Cape not a superhero cape just a
cape
absolutely Bonkers everyone's Bonkers
huh
[Music]
let's look at some of these deserved
scales God that that one last time of
the [__] kid who was like
go ahead rob me [__] and they
took his shoes and [__]
here we go deserved skill
that's gonna go back and hit him oh that
was a good one hit his legs that was
good if he hit his mouth it would have
been tough but that he deserved it wow
that's a pretty good kind of throws one
of those stupid signs up in the air
comes back smashes him the most so
Australian
it's like a boomerang
um
wow that's a an eight that's a good one
but it didn't really have the humor
Factory but it kind of did have a humor
I like her uh okay here we go
yep yep there we go and that's a nine
yep
so drunk dude I'm so sorry dude smashed
his lady into the [__] TV set
that was [__] he said
wait hold on is that a guy
in a dress
[Music]
I'm so sorry so wow you know
woke up with a big ass [__] nose
looked like Bradley Cooper was playing
her
um
uh
uh let's do here
while flipping into water oh I saw this
one dude
this guy doesn't really deserve that but
my God
dude if I'm there and that happens I go
like that when this is what this is me
in the thing
this is me if I see my friend do that
uh we need a new friend he's dead
dude that is a [__] nigh that's like
a four or four he didn't deserve it
that's you know what he's probably used
to diving boards and that [__] was not
forgiving at all and he just tried to do
it and then [__] crushed his mouth
Jesus Christ
oh we did that one oh this one's good to
review again yeah jumping over the sign
[Music]
we did that one before but that's a
[__] nine I wonder what I rated it
last time
oh he does okay hold on
to the beginning
all of that
Zone
hands in the middle yeah oh wow dude
hands in the middle [__] slamming up
against the edge of it smashing my
[__] teeth and here we go here we go
wow
God you know just no business doing that
at all Here Comes Tinder let's look at
some Tinder things
dudes talking to matches while zonked on
acid hell yeah it's my kind of dude
these would be guys who go to my show
um hey the girl says and the guy says
I'm on acid right now you have very very
dark energies around you I think it's
best I don't associate with your kind
all the best unmatching now she says
what he says I'm on [__] and then
drugs and then under and the energies
tell me you are wrong good [__] bye
dude I don't really don't think people
on drugs are funny because it's like
that's the excuse It's like well they're
on drugs dude but this one's good wow
that's a good one and copying that one
I'm gonna tell my friends
um
that's a good one Wow Come on get back
here we go here's another one
oh that one doesn't exist anymore crying
[__] absolutely great
here we go online dating at its finest
I'm okay I'd be better if I was balls
deep inside you though ew that dude just
said that wow he's and then she said
Gross she says worth a shot
does he respond after this or is that it
God I'm okay I'm okay exclamation point
two of them I'd be better if I was balls
deep inside you though smiley face dude
don't you know that's not gonna work
that's like whistling outside of a
[__]
car to a woman
there we go
okay this starts with no you okay what's
the mug shot about he says to her she
says I got arrested for what nothing bad
for real all right you good looking for
a
FWB kind of thing [__] Friends with
Benefits kind of thing uh yeah before I
gotta go to jail not for real what did
you do she says attempted murder
damn you're scared of me
guys will look past whatever huh
hey what's up I'm a dude that's all good
you looking for a [__] buddy or ma'am
um
like I think okay let's look at some
misconnections it's time for
misconnections do you like to eat donut
holes
it says and the subject looking for
those that like to eat donut holes okay
talking about [__] huh how about that
nice
uh
all right you know what that's it that
we're gonna hand another that one
because that's he's talking about eating
[__] and we'd love to end it on that
I think we did on one of those last
episodes but uh yeah I'm gonna be in
Charlotte Knoxville and Little Rock and
also Nashville and
Canada go to chrisley.com and that's it
for this episode
um if you want to watch the rest of it
on this is for YouTube if you want to
watch the rest of it on patreon go over
to patreon.com patreon.com
and uh help us keep the show going by
your uh support we really appreciate you
if you're on patreon and we also
appreciate you if you're not but leave a
comment and uh we'll see on the next one
[Music]
thank you
foreign